it's time for roses and Cabernet hi you
guys a red wine for a cold winter night
hey everybody i'm lauren zima thank you
so much for watching roses in Rose day
we are getting into our elion dykes
season of The Bachelor the fourth
episode and things are getting better
yes tonight we had sexy champagne and
cool settings we had drama drama drama
and we had re starting to really analyze
himself which I really liked
let's dive in yes so I have this red
wine because it's the winter and because
the crew went up to Tahoe like Tahoe and
it was full of snow and mountains and
cozy sweaters and Becca's faux furs and
I just liked it it was a good episode a
couple of drinking games that were
playing tonight first drink every time
someone got to have champagne in an
awesome place second drink every time
Ari says something really self-aware I
want to be as much a cheerleader for you
know the person I'm with as they are for
me and it shows the sign of maturity
actually so there's it's 2 2 factor you
got have 2 of those quality and drink
every time crystal says something really
mean about somebody else it's just not
at a level that I play at things that
crystal said about the other women
included calling them obnoxious
overbearing juvenile aggressive and
desperate I mean I love the drama though
I don't love women hating on women
without good we get nobody should hit
anybody without good reason
cien Stan gets a one-on-one I'm not
really gonna get into it other than to
say that I really like CN she seems
beautiful and smart I'm glad she got a
one-on-one or two still on the show and
I hope to see more of her that's all I
can say about CN that's the end on CN
right no I don't yeah we get into
Becca's age discussion she's 22 re is 36
we also find out Becca is gonna get a
one-on-one and of course crystal weighs
it
she's just so young she's definitely
still searching for identity a woman not
a girl crystal says that Becca is still
searching for her identity and that re
needs not a girl but a woman the wisdom
of Britney Spears
[Music]
I mean I don't think that a 22 year old
is a girl I think that is a woman let's
not I mean it's just I think that Becca
is very mature I do think that there's a
difference between being mature and
being in a certain life place though and
it's not the back of being 22 means
she's immature but she hasn't had a lot
of life experiences yet just because she
has another time to experience them so
maybe she's not ready for marriage okay
let's get into it and please let me know
what you think of the age issue in the
comments below and also McHale had to go
home because she found out her
grandfather died which was very sad
but I would like to remind that McKell
is only 23 so why is everyone getting on
Becca about being 22 it's a one-year
difference okay they go on this group
date first and they go hiking and it's
gonna be all about survival and they
have to pee and what looked like swell
bottles is then we're gonna use those
bottles again they're like those like
double insulated bottles and then we
think that our II drink drank his own
pee to survive I'm impressed
he didn't
disappointing I wish he had you know
would have been bold okay and then the
women eat worms and I'd probably rather
eat bugs and drink my own pee I don't
know I'm just trying to get us over this
and then they have to find their way out
of the mountains and this is my
nightmare oh my god I am so bad at
directions it was a fatal flaw I
literally always picked the wrong way to
go this is actually a nightmare but the
reward at the end of finding your way
out of the woods is they get to have
champagne in a cool place mmm OCN Inari
had champagne on the beach that was also
champagne in a cool place mmm I like
these dates even though I hate getting
lost so you're painting like a hot tub
no I was like yes crystals saying things
like it's just not at a level that I
play at meeting it's down here I don't
think this is a game and she says that
you know this just feels like high
school and she's almost 30
I'm confused than through no it's
reality TV you signed up to be on a
television show crystal that I'm getting
through the women but we're still at
that stage we're like we don't really
know all of them so Ari and Lauren B
have a moment and that's nice because I
didn't really know who Lauren B was yet
and there's a lot of Laurens and by the
way I talked to Lauren asked today on e
t--'s Facebook page and it was live and
shameless plug she gave a great
interview she's lovely and talked about
you know what life was really like with
Arie so great so here's the thing about
crystal she was getting a little bit of
hate - you know like where's the fish
you know kissing his ass
so there are two sides to this because
crystal keeps saying that like the women
are putting a target on her back and
whatever but the problem with crystal is
that she always takes things one step
too far it's just like.how Bibiana was
saying you know crystal gets too much
time and crystals stole re but then went
back for a second time that was one step
too far and tonight crystal was saying
she had a target on her back and then
she took things one step too far when
she said to re really and so it hurts
her when other people don't come from
that place were you coming from a place
of love when you said that everyone was
like a high school juvenile girl seeking
attention desperately and that it wasn't
at the level you play at mm-hm
drinking every time that re shows some
self-awareness and growth you told
Lauren B that he wants to be as much of
a cheerleader for the person he's with
as they are for him so like equal
cheerleading and that's great because
last week Becca said that maybe re only
dates women who need him and he
knowledge that might be true growth
growth reflection moving forward great I
love it people say that on this show you
just have so much time to analyze
yourself that you're going to change as
a person intense therapy and lots of
time to work out people say not to go on
the show for the wrong reasons you know
it's all about going on the show for the
right reasons I feel we need to abandon
that you guys yes you should go on the
show looking for love but to go I mean
you know going to a store to buy one
thing you know like maybe somebody goes
on the show hoping to fall in love and
hoping for personal growth to make
friends to travel even Sean and
Catherine Lowe the franchise's golden
couple
said on the countdown to our special
that they went on the show trying to
have a fun vacation so it's okay you
know and Arie is on the show getting
personal growth now Kendall tells Arie
that she's always wanted to eat a bunch
of bugs and that she's traveling with a
dead stuffed duck she had brought ping
ever
named ping I brought him with me music
traveling how do you travel with a
taxidermy do you just put in your check
those are my notes son Kendall one thing
that is hard for me to tell about Aria's
he's saying that he has a lot of
chemistry with a lot of people like
singing has great chemistry with Lauren
beat with Kendall with Becca it's making
it tough to tell how he's really feeling
but he does get more open about his
feelings tonight which I like
I think he's open to the process but
we're just now seeing him be open with
his feelings to the viewing audience
which is great and just feel really
proud of like overcoming all those
challenges oh my gosh I mean crystal
gets to the point where I'm not even
quite sure what she's talking about
anymore because she says that she's
flawless she's a little busy
and everything she does is perfect
you're losing me crystal one step too
far it's like drinking too much you know
it's not a good idea okay Becca and Arie
go on their one-on-one and she does the
run and jump to him and she's wearing
faux fur again remember last week she
told us she loves fur and they get
champagne in a hot tub this show
wonderful she has a strong independent
sexiness to her she's so mature Arie
even says before he knows her age that
Becca is so mature foreshadowing of him
having a strong reaction to finding out
her age and he did Becca and I are
talking we do know how old I am no I
don't and he's like I don't and that
kind of made me realize you know maybe
she thought producers had told him her
age so she had to tell him and he
covered his mouth in horror and then
we're gonna drink again for Arie
self-reflection and maturity because he
says you know he's having these really
strong feelings for Becca but he thinks
that she might not be ready for marriage
and in the past he's really led with
chemistry but he's trying not to do that
because he really wants to settle down
and he also again gives us that example
that he wakes up so early and goes to
sleep so early and it's obvious that
that means that he's old and mature
which like I'm kind of over that example
but also I'm with him on this I'm with
him on this I enjoy
like waking up with the Sun which I
never enjoyed five years ago and he says
that he wants a wife from you know why
not a 22 year old girlfriend hmm but
then he didn't give back of the rose he
really likes her he really likes you
guys I'm getting the sense now I'm
predicting that they don't end up
together because this life play stuff is
gonna be a problem but man if she was a
few years older I think it could have
been a thing and I'd love to see her as
a Bachelorette like Jake cute little
girl
JC likes her too he's smiling mm-hmm I
have to catch a flight like right after
this for a really fun reason that you
will know soon okay Arie being
distraught about Becca was the most
emotionally real I've seen him be yet
this season and so I'm feeling great
emotions are great that's it he knows
exactly we wants to do tonight Arie
sticking to his theme which has been
that he is ready to cut people when he
knows who he wants to cut decides
there's not gonna be a cocktail party oh
he's just gonna go straight to the rose
ceremony and given that crystal has been
talking so much about how flawless and
confident and perfect she is her
reaction was to freak the F out and that
was surprising because you know again
she just thinks she and I are meant to
be but she's like I need to steal you
for a minute I'm sorry would you mind if
I just had a quick moment of your time
yeah again one step too far and she
talks to Arie and then you know not to
shockingly he didn't eliminate her
anyway Caroline went home which is sad
because she seemed cool I didn't know
her that well but she seemed cool and
Brittany went home and she was kind of
funny but I didn't really know her at
all but next wait I don't know how she's
supposed
to redeem this why are you still here
okay next week in the promo it tease
that things are really gonna hit the fan
with Krystal overall you guys a good
episode a cosy episode I like watching
TV that transports me to like a certain
weather vibe place you know there's
something
it's like travel porn you know when you
watch this show you like oh I mean like
Tahoe right it's snowing the snow is
really coming down it's real unless the
producers put it there and you know they
didn't find it's like it's not even
locked everything escapism isn't it
wonderful
again I will send this message you guys
look oh sorry
probably someone weighing in on
tonight's episode look this show
features real people who become a little
bit of caricatures because they're on a
reality TV and I have certain reactions
to those caricatures and to the episodes
that doesn't mean that we have to hate
on those real people in real life
they're people with perfections and
flaws and yes they agreed to be on
reality TV but they also didn't have
their whole person shown on TV because
your whole person can't fit in a few
minutes of a TV episode you know so
[Music]
that's just my PSA and just because we
might be on Team this or team that
doesn't mean we hate the other team you
know 2018 ok thanks so much for watching
we will be back here next week with
another episode of course I really
always love hearing you guys's thoughts
on the shows and when you do your deep
dives in the comments section so please
leave them below I love you so much have
a great night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]